hello readers today we are going on a
dangerous journey inside the mind of the
author
every piece of text is written for a
purpose and especially in informational
texts every author structures their
texts words and their ideas with that
purpose in mind
and sometimes that purpose will be
harder to see
as readers our job is to consider the
author's purpose as we read
how is it influencing the information
the author shares how is it influencing
my understanding of the topic
is what i think the same as what the
author thinks do i agree with them do i
disagree
you may be familiar with the memory
device of pi
persuade inform entertain as three
categories of purpose but i'd like to go
deeper than that
i live in washington dc which is home to
an entire professional class of what are
called lobbyists people whose job it is
to advocate to congress on behalf of a
special interest for example the oil
industry or the cheese industry this
isn't always bad you can learn more
about lobbyists and advocates and khan
academy's government and politics course
but frequently it takes the form of
someone from an industry trying to
convince congress to give them a
competitive advantage over other
industries now let's pull real world
politics out of this and pretend for the
purposes of this lesson that there are
two warring lobby groups in dc one that
represents the cake industry and another
that represents the pie industry
an age-old conflict
so hold that conflict in your mind for a
second cake versus pie now when we read
informational text we should be learning
new information but the author's
opinions can shape the text to the point
where the information becomes biased or
misleading
when you read informational text
maintain an air of healthy skepticism
ask yourself the following questions
constantly
what's the author's opinion what
information did they include or what
information did they leave out and if so
was that on purpose what's the
connotation of the author's word choice
you know how do the words feel
and and what's the overall tone
of the piece
so now we have these questions to ask
ourselves let's return to our pie versus
cake lobby fight in washington
so imagine you're reading the washington
post and you see this opinion column
cake connected to cavities and poor
dental health study fines
a recent study by the american dental
association connected the consumption of
cake or similar foods with a 30
increased risk of tooth decay cavities
and gingivitis
people who reported having consumed cake
in the previous 60 days were
significantly more likely to experience
problems related to dental health than
those people who did not cake is
dangerous cake which rarely contains
fruit will rot your teeth
and then if we squint down at the very
bottom of the column it'll say in small
text the author is the ceo of circular
solutions a pie advocacy network and now
let's ask ourselves those same questions
again while acknowledging that this is a
fake story that i made up for the
purposes of this video there is nobody
named wendell apricot jam although i
wish there were that'd be a great name
so what's the author's opinion well it
seems to me that the author really
thinks cake is dangerous and poses a
threat to the nation's dental health we
know this because they literally say
cake is dangerous they want people to
buy and eat fewer cakes
what information did the author choose
to include well so this is interesting
the author talks about the results of
this study and the big takeaways about
the danger of cake or similar foods and
then they go on to mention incidentally
that cake rarely contains fruit that's a
curious thing to say it's almost like
they're saying pie which has fruit in it
is better for you than cake without
actually saying it
what information did the author choose
to leave out well notice that the piece
says cake or similar foods
i would be hard-pressed to come up with
a definition of foods similar to cake
that does not also include desserts like
pie but the way that this piece is
written it swerves out of its way to
avoid pinning the same tooth decay risks
on pie the way that it blames cake
i think it would be reasonable to assume
that if we read the underlying study
that this opinion piece is based on it
would include pies and cakes in the same
category of sugary desserts that are
associated with bad dental outcomes
why would the author do this
well they want you to buy pie instead of
cake but they don't want you to think
too hard about it because if you did you
would buy and eat both less cake and
less pie
and the pie lobby doesn't want that
what's the connotation or the feeling of
the author's word choices well they're
citing a scientific study by dentists so
they want you to take their warning
seriously and they're using words like
risk and danger
rot and problems
they want you to make an association
between eating cake and bad tooth health
they want you to associate scientific
language with trustworthiness
so i'm going to put down scientific
authority here
what's the overall tone it's negative
the author does not want you to eat cake
they want you to think it's bad and
they've planted a little hint here that
fruity foods are better what's a fruity
food pie can they say pie is safer no
not without lying outright
now i want to be clear about two things
sometimes an author's purpose really
will just be to inform straightforwardly
not everything has to be a tug-of-war
between you and the author over the
truth sometimes a writer just wants you
to know the life cycle of a butterfly or
how to make egg salad or the order the
u.s presidents came in but most of the
time there's a purpose and opinion
behind the text now the second thing i
want to be super clear about is that i i
made up this whole thing i made up the
article the statistics
wendell you know uh all of that's fake
um i like both pie and cake very much
and now that i've said that i'm sure
you're wondering oh is david in the
pocket of big dessert and the answer is
no i'm in the pocket of big free
education for everyone everywhere
you can learn anything
dave it out